(whoosh)
(pop)
- This is black and white,
I don't know what emotional
hurdle you need to get over
to get into this, I don't
know if you don't realize
how content you actually are,
I don't know if you don't
realize that the words
coming out of your mouth
from ambition don't match your action,
cause you don't actually
mean it, I don't know what,
but I know it's happening.
And that's what we need to
breakthrough here today.
(sirens)
(men shouting)
You got your perspective
(escalating music)
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
(upbeat electronic music)
YouTube what's up?
So, so grateful that you
clicked and you're about
to watch a new YouTube video,
but before you do 212-931-5731,
that is my texting community
platform, I'm doing
a lot of one-on-one engagement in there
and also access opportunity first looks
in that environment, 212-931-5731,
join it now.
And now to the video you've
been wanting to watch.
So, super excited to be here.
A lot to talk about, I also
spoke with the organizer
so I'm gonna try to do
quite a bit of Q and A,
because I think the framework
of where I see the opportunity
for many in the room is
not overly complicated.
And what I'd really like to do is,
give this audience the
opportunity to ask a detailed
question about maybe their
attempts within the execution
and why it didn't work, or
how they see the perspectives
in a different way.
So
very simply to set up this conversation,
I believe that attention
is the singular most important asset
for anybody trying to achieve
anything, whether that's
to cure a disease, run for
office, sell a sneaker,
get a client, to create
anything, to create anything
you need ones attention
and then the variable
of what comes out of your
mouth or what you create
becomes the way it happens.
I have had an incredibly
interesting relationship
with attention my whole
life, it took me probably
until five years ago
really questioning you know
in a knock on wood why is
this going so well way,
what has allowed me to
be successful, what else
has allowed me to be happy and successful?
Why is this working?
Why is this so obvious
to me, yet continues
to not be for the masses?
What is this thing?
What is my life, why does this work?
And what it took me
back to, ironically is,
which would make sense,
everyone's origin stories,
but it becomes a DNA thing.
At some level the thing that,
actually brings me happiness
is I can't hear the cheering
and I can't hear the booing,
and that's why it's very easy
to navigate through life.
That came from probably the
circumstances of being born
in the Soviet Union, coming
to America, very humble
beginnings, you know studio apartment,
multiple family members in it.
You know, complete and
utter lack of entitlement,
while also having a wildly
loving mother who built
disproportionate self
esteem, but knew how to stop
right before it became delusion.
(audience laughing)
And that is really the
balance I think many parents
in the room are trying to
figure out and we're starting
to understand eighth place trophies
are a really stupid fucking idea.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
And so that happened, but
where it really took me to
was my first business, which
was a lemonade stand business,
when I was six, seven years old.
I legitimately tricked my
friends into standing behind
lemonade stands all day and
I used to tell that story
in my early keynote career, and
then I actually in a keynote
while I was telling the story
in the other part of my brain
was trying to figure out
what was I doing all day
if they were all behind..
Like I actually couldn't recall
and then finally triggered,
what I was doing was I was
making signs for five to seven
hours a day as a seven year old,
walking the streets of New Jersey sitting
on corners watching cars drive by
and trying to legitimately
figure out which tree,
or which sign, or which
bush, or what angle
their eyes were looking
at while they were driving
and where to put my sign.
I did not learn that in
college, I did not learn that
by watching a keynote video
on YouTube, I did not learn
that reading a Seth Godin book.
You know, I learned it because
it was inherently in me
and then it transformed forever.
I did baseball card shows when I was 13,
making $4,000 a weekend,
I was the only dealer
amongst grown men, to spend
the first four or five hours
not setting up my table but
walking around and understanding
where the attention was going.
I would spend a lot of
time looking at my table
and understanding where to put things,
because I knew they'd be walking by fast
and could I stop them
with a Ken Griffy Jr.
or a Micheal Jordan whatever it was.
I'd been chasing attention my whole life.
That manifested when I
transitioned in to my Dad's
liquor store business
and it really transformed
because I stood behind
the register and I watched
people walk through the
store, and the first impact
I had on my Dad's business
was moving around things.
I said, "Dad, when people first
walk in we should not have
a huge display of $6 stuff, we should
have a display of $12."
It was just, it came natural,
it continues to come natural.
I have written more books than I've read.
I consume almost no content
other than reading peoples
comments to things that
are going on in the world.
I know that Felix Hernandez
retired from baseball last night
by sitting in the green room
right now reading 20 peoples
comments about it.
I only care about the end consumer.
I only care about the potential customer,
and I care about her and
his behaviors and attention.
I do not care what's currently
working for you to get leads.
I don't care what's currently
working for me to get leads.
I'm always putting what's
working yesterday through massive
friction of is that behavior best today.
I built my Dad's liquor store from a three
to a 60 million dollar
business in five years,
on the back of spending
every penny properly
even though the data
showed me that direct mail,
and newspapers, and radios
would work better than email
and google search.
It didn't matter what it was
showing me, what mattered was
what were human beings doing right now.
To be a person in this
room looking for leads
and growing their business,
and to not think social media
works is audacious at best
and downright fucking stupid at worst.
(audience laughing)
Now I understand why people think that,
because like anything in
life the ROI of something
is completely predicated
on how good you are at it.
The ROI of a basketball is a
billion dollars for LeBron,
it's zero for me.
(audience laughing)
Just cause you ran $1,000
worth of Facebook ads
and it didn't work doesn't mean
that Facebook doesn't work,
it means that you suck.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
That is not my opinion,
that is my knowledge that
the shopping app Wish has
spent 95% of its money
on Facebook and has become
a business that sells
eight billion dollars worth of product.
That is not my opinion
that Instagram can work,
it's that Fahionova does a
billion dollars in revenue
on the back of 100% Instagram
influencer strategy.
I for the record could give
zero shits about social media,
I can not wait to give a
keynote in 10 years making fun
of people doing social media,
because voice or augmented
reality, or blockchain, or
whatever is being invented
by a 13 year old girl
in Tennessee right now,
is the better thing to do than right now.
Now, this does not mean
that something is dead,
I'm very happy for you if your
billboards are converting.
I'm thrilled if your direct
mail strategy is rocking it.
My question is, is that the
best use of your $4,000?
Just cause you get 18 leads
from it, could you get 49
from something else you spent $4,000 on?
This is the debate at hand.
If there is anybody who's
confused that this is
the single most important
thing in our society
then you're just downright confused.
These plat...I literally
sit with friends including
this, I have a friend
deeply in this industry
and we were having a conversation year ago
which is why I was so excited
to come and give this talk,
and the debate, the
conversation starts with...
And actually I won't use his
cause he didn't go that far
into it let me actually
paint a much clearer picture.
I spend my life sitting down
with people about marketing.
and communications, and business,
and they'll spend the first 30 minutes,
and it's a little less white
hot right now but the elections
not too far away so it's
gonna come up again,
but a year and a half ago
I would literally spend
the first 30 minutes of a
one hour business breakfast
with the executive telling
me that Facebook is terrible.
Or social media is terrible,
it's ruining our democracy.
And all this stuff, it
literally is all this
and then when we would segway,
into the normal business.
This one meeting sits
in my mind the gentleman
is the CO of one of the major
beauty brands in the world,
we're talking about makeup.
He basically looked me in
the face 20 minutes later
and said, "Look, I just
don't think Instagram
and Facebook can sell makeup."
(audience laughing)
"I really believe in Vogue."
And all this other horse shit.
(audience laughing)
And I said to him, I
took a step back I said,
"Lub it, five seconds just
for myself cause I'm confused
here over my scrambled eggs.
This is correct what you're
saying, you're telling me
in this breakfast, that
Facebook and social media
is so powerful
that it can destroy one of
the most powerful things
in the world, the American democracy,
but it can't sell lipstick?"
(audience clapping)
It's real.
Let me make it perfectly clear
before we get into Q and A,
I have zero point zero
interest in you doing anything
that I talk about this morning.
You're not my mother,
you're not my brother,
I genuinely don't give a fuck about you.
(audience laughing)
I am doing this keynote
because it's being filmed
and I wanna be historically
correct, and I will
re-air it in eight years when I'm talking
about something else.
And if you follow me on
Instagram I've quite enjoyed
the last year of pulling
up my videos from eight,
and nine, and seven, and 12 years ago,
because I'm looking to
build my reputation.
If you wanna go back home and
do exactly what you're doing,
I actually am happy about
that, because the less money
that you put into these systems
is making that attention
a better deal for me.
So there's no confusion,
I prefer you don't
do anything I'm talking
about this morning.
(audience laughing)
And the good news for me for
doing this for the last decade,
is I know that 98% of you will not.
(audience laughing)
I will do a nice job here
over the next 44 minutes,
we will get fired up, a lot
of things are gonna make
sense to you in its mix
of cursing and comedy,
I will answer very direct
questions that show you
I have deep practitioner ship in this.
This isn't fucking college up here,
this is everyday real life.
I've built two businesses from scratch,
one from scratch excuse
me to a 200 million dollar
business over the last nine years,
in revenue, profitable, not valuation.
(audience laughing)
Uh, I built a three
million dollar business
doing $300,000 in gross
profit before expenses,
with no credit line and
no venture back money
to a 60 million dollar
business in five years
as a 22 year old.
I'm Mariano Rivera, and if
you don't know what that means
Mariano Rivera
(audience clapping)
is a hall of fame pitcher
that just retired and went
to the hall of fame recently,
played for the New York Yankees.
He was an extremely good
pitcher, he was their closer
for two decades, but
ultimately if you're a hardcore
baseball knowledgeable
fan, he had one pitch.
He had one pitch that
literally not one human being,
besides Edgar Martinez, knew how to hit.
And that's me,
I suck at a lot of things,
the one thing I don't suck at
is understanding what the
consumer is doing at this second.
I understand human behavior
and I understand human
attention, and I understand
it not like buying
a mutual fund, I understand
it like day trading.
I know exactly what's
happening right this second,
on LinkedIn, on Tik Tok,
on Facebook, on Twitter,
on YouTube, in print
magazines, on the radio,
in billboards, on t.v., on
Netflix, period end of story.
And that currency
is going to be the single
most important thing
in perpetuity, because
as the internet continues
to evolve everything in
the middle is commoditized.
The amount of people that
give a shit of what college
you went to or how many
years of experience you have,
is staggeringly low.
Knowing who you are is
super duper important.
This industry as a whole
has had a quite a historic
understanding of personalities
being able to build
quite big businesses by
arbitraging where the attention
of the consumer was.
Sometimes that's outdoor
media, sometimes that's direct
mail, often for the tippy top
it has been remnant television
commercials, today that
opportunity sits at scale
at an under priced nature
in pre roll YouTube.
Everybody is so obsessed
with leads and conversion,
which is why if you're
current you love search,
you love SEM, obviously
if somebody's typing
something in that's intent.
And I understand why
everybody loves it here,
cause 99.9999% of this room
is in the sales business,
not in the brand and marketing business.
It's short term conversion, it's math.
This is why I always beat you.
I always beat sales people.
Sales people look at short term ROI,
I don't care if I'm losing
27 to 3 at half time,
what's the score at the end dick?
(audience laughing)
That is my marketing strategy.
You being completely a no
name on these social platforms
means you are in the process
of becoming less relevant.
Where do you think we're going, you think
this is going backwards?
You think we're gonna wake
up tomorrow and give up
our cell phones?
If you are not relevant
in building brand today,
let me actually go right to the punchline,
how many people here are spending
money on Google Ad Words?
Or search, or care about SEO,
just raise your hands high.
High, makes sense.
And I'm a fan, I built
my Dad's business on it.
You wanna talk about a real good Google,
I was there day one,
literally day one, the words
were five cents a click,
I owned the word wine
for five cents for four months.
(audience laughing)
Nobody knew what it was, it wasn't good.
I went to little conferences,
conferences as big
as that table at the
Springfield New Jersey
chamber of commerce event,
where the guy who was selling
yellow pages made fun of
me for this internet fad.
I remember those days.
Those days are happening right now.
Of course you can't like
putting out organic content
on Facebook, or Instagram,
or LinkedIn, or anywhere else
as much as a Google search term.
That's a conversion.
There's intent.
It happens quick.
The math is right there.
You can't see what happens
when you're building equity
and brand, it takes time I understand.
I'm happy, I'm happy that
everyone is so this second,
this basic math, this not thoughtful.
This is my great advantage,
it doesn't make it
any less true.
Let me tell you exactly how
search is gonna play out
over the next decade.
How many people actually,
how many people here
are retiring within the next six years
and before you raise
your hand I don't mean
you're gonna crush it
over the next six years
and buy a fucking yacht,
I mean you're fucking old
and you're finished.
(audience laughing)
So real quick, hands, next six years.
Raise your hands, retiring
next six years firm.
Okay.
So for the five of you,
(audience laughing)
for the five of you, I think at some level
you can take some of this
with a grain of salt,
but for the rest of you
pay very close attention
to something that is about to
happen over the next decade
that will be very important.
Why I'm telling you that brand
over search or conversion
will transform your businesses.
In a decade when somebody
needs you they will be
in their kitchen, in their
car, in their office,
and they will say, "Alexis."
Alexa, excuse me.
Alexa, Google, Apple,
Samsung, or whoever wins,
"I need a lawyer."
What are you gonna do then?
Just curious, what are you gonna do then?
Are you gonna be so clever with your copy,
there is nothing left besides brand.
When that voice machine
gives an answer in the back,
either they will give
the business they bought
and take all the business,
or if you think Google
search terms are expensive
wait til you see what a
referral from a voice device
is gonna cost you.
Oh and oh by the way, only
one person can get it.
You don't see 11 people, I
don't get to make a choice
because you put a clever name in it,
or I like the way your last
name sounds, or you got some
sort of other variable,
it's a binary thing
and you better be in the
fucking business of this,
"Alexa, get me Susan Thompson."
Cause if you're not,
you're gonna be finished.
And that is how it's gonna play out.
So, I hope you keep enjoying
your philosophy of lead
generations and sales driven,
I'm super excited that
you can't figure out
how to put out content
and give people advice
of how to avoid using you,
or how to avoid getting in
trouble, or other things
that people should learn, which
would then give you equity.
This is real and in a room
where only five people
are retiring in the next
six years, and by the way
three of them looked way
too young to be retiring
in like the next six years.
I highly recommend everybody
understands that we're
in a massive crossroads in
technology where personal brand
is not some foofy thing,
or some audacious thing,
or something we look down on
cause we don't like the word
cause what it really means is reputation.
You don't like the word
personal brand fine,
call it reputation.
I have a funny feeling
a lot of people in here
know exactly what that means.
And if you are not putting
out content at scale
on LinkedIn, and YouTube, and Instagram,
and whatever else emerges,
if you do not have a podcast
around what you do for a
living, or show up on podcasts.
If you are not digitally native
because either A,
traditional media of print,
radio, television, and
those are other things
are appeasing you enough and
you're only digital behavior
is just sales driven
intent from search queries
and you're overpaying of the
next guy or the next gal,
a little bit more to be the
first result in Google Ad Words,
your strategy is uncomfortably vulnerable.
Now, how do I know this?
Not super complicated.
I gave this talk to the
2011 Limo and Car services
and told them this Uber
thing was not a joke,
and they laughed me out of the room.
I went in 2014 to Toys'R'Us,
which was my favorite
store as a kid, to meet
with the CO, and pleaded
not even for the business, for them
to change their strategy.
I don't have to tell you what
happened to that business.
The bookstores were
very naive about Amazon.
This is historical, this is
not I'm a prophet, a futurist,
you know, I'm not fucking Yoda.
I
just respect two core things,
what customers are
actually doing this second
and history always repeating itself.
I just don't understand how
anybody is not pot committed
in a service business
predicated on human beings
in building awareness
around that human being.
And that's it, so that's
what I think is happening,
I couldn't recommend a couple things more.
And we're about to do Q and A
so start thinking about questions.
Couple things, number one,
when producing content
to use it as a lead gen
for your business, the number
one rule is to do everything
reverse of what you're feeling right now.
You have to make content that
actually brings people value
and not mix in a sales call.
It's very disciplined, it's
very difficult, it's why
I wrote a book called "Jab,
Jab, Jab, Right Hook" years ago.
Give, give, give, and then ask.
Too many people bleed
their give and their ask
in the same piece of content,
thus it's actually an ask.
Thus, you don't convert.
Building equity in the
ecosystem around things that
you've learned from your
experience, whatever that may be,
is completely imperative.
There's also a lot of people
that may just hire you
cause you're a Chief's fan
and sharing that variable matters too.
You don't have to, I produce more...
How many people here
follow me in social at all?
So the hands that just went up thank you.
The hands that just, you
may know nobody produces
more content a day than me,
I've got 100 pieces going across
11 platforms, but I share
nothing about my personal life,
no family stuff.
You're fully in control,
the machine and algorithm
don't take you over, you get to put out
what you want to put out.
But you have to provide value
not put out a sales call.
Number two, you have to be self aware
of how you communicate.
There are a lot of people in
here that would never put out
a video because they don't feel good about
the way they look, they're
insecure when that camera
light goes on.
They just don't like it and
that's fine, that's amazing.
Not everybody is wildly
charismatic and handsome, I get it.
(audience laughing)
However, many of you here
can write 11 sentences
in a way that I never could
and post something on LinkedIn
that would absolutely crush and
become the awareness to you.
Maybe you draw well, I'm
not kidding, some of my best
content right now is the
transformation of the things
I believe into comic format
that looks like a Sunday comic.
Maybe you're audio, maybe
you're the kind of guy or gal
that walks around earth has a
thought, started to understand
the kind of value people are
looking for and you take out
your iPhone or your phone,
and you hit record and it's
a memo, and you talk for
two minutes and you hit stop
and you post that on these platforms.
Communication has been
established a long time ago,
it's visual, it's audio,
it's drawings, it's videos,
it's words, it's basic.
Radio, television, print,
is the internet now,
it's all the same shit.
You have to figure out
how you communicate.
Unable to be you, you're a one woman shop,
you better understand
why Metlife has Snoopy.
You wanna go real extreme?
You're super private, you can't do it,
you can't put yourself out
there, it's really interesting
for you to come up with a logo,
to come up with a character
to speak on your behalf.
Not building brand on the
digital platforms of today
is completely unacceptable,
and before some classic dog
raise their hands and says,
"Gary, I didn't grow up
with this shit, that's
why I'm not doing it."
I wanna remind everybody in
this room, none of us grew up
with this shit and more
importantly the customer doesn't
care that you were born in 1964,
or 1952,
or 49, or 92.
You didn't grow up driving
you figured it out.
And before you off source
this to your 23 year old niece
cause she's young,
(audience laughing)
I wanna remind you that
if this is your business
it is now as important in
one mans opinion, I could
be wrong, it's as important
to understand this as it is
to balance your checkbook.
If your business and
company does not understand
contemporary communication,
it is far more vulnerable
than you think.
It just is.
This is happening quickly.
Please be thoughtful, please
audit your businesses,
please notice a lot of your
clients may be historical
and that there is no lead
gen, that you're not acquiring
new leads in the classic way.
Or more importantly, don't
get high on your own supply,
if somethings working now
cause you're crushing some
search term or you got some
ad buy, and that actually
represents 63% of all your
business, A things change,
and B the whole thing breaks.
Somebody was crushing this
industry on the yellow pages,
cause they were AAA lawyer
guy
and then that medium went away.
You have no ability to
be successful in AR, VR,
blockchain, machine learning,
new platforms, all the things
that are coming in the
next decade if you are not
at least somewhat capable of
understanding what's happening
now, you're gonna miss
the whole middle part.
One of the biggest reasons
I implore people here
to produce content at
scale on these platforms,
is just to get on the treadmill
of being a digital native
communicator, because
when the next thing comes
and it does really crush what you're doing
you're not even gonna know where to start.
This is why everybody declines,
this is why everybody declines.
I don't want you to decline.
I wanna empathically
create energy in this room
that might make three people actually say,
"Fuck it, it's time."
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
(phone ring)
Hey guys sorry to interrupt your video,
I'm just giving you
this call from my number
to let you know that you have
to join my text community.
212-931-5731,
hit me up with a text.
(audience clapping)
Let's go right here.
How are you sir?
- [Paul] Very good.
- Uh I need you to stand up
for your questions please
for the videos.
So keep your hands up we'll
get to as many as possible.
I'll go fast.
- [Paul] A very good big fan follow ya.
- Thank you, what's your name?
- Paul Thaus.
- Paul.
- Friends of Ryan Alovis, texted you.
- Yes.
- [Paul] Do you have a sense
of, you know, percentage
when you're spending like
right when you say LinkedIn
is where I see Facebook was,
and how much should a brand
be spending on the platforms
of today, the Facebook,
LinkedIn, and what percentage
should we be testing on?
I mean I just set up a Tik
Tok account with nieces
I have no idea, is it 5% and
throwing out to these other
things that might happen.
Versus where's the..?
- I, please let me bang
on that real quick.
Yes we can get a picture but
we'll do that at the end,
but to answer your question,
I think of it as three stages.
The majority of people here
are spending their dollars
in something that I
think has less of an ROI
than Facebook, and LinkedIn, and podcast
advertising right now.
So I would spend 70, and
these are arbitrary numbers
intuition, I'm going 70
there, I'm taking my 100
or 80 of the traditional stuff,
Google search, direct mail,
I'm taking that to 20 and
then I'm doing five or 10%
of weird new stuff just
to get myself used to it.
The problem is, 99.999% of this
room is not going to do that
because within the first 100
days you'll have a decline
of leads and they'll
bail cause they're soft.
(audience laughing)
Hi.
- [Amy] Hi, Amy Refeca.
- Hi Amy.
- [Amy] So fascinatingly we
are in a industry that's super
traditional, we're lawyers,
doctors, accountant right,
we're one of those three.
But we barely rank above
prostitutes in trust
according right, according
to all the media the surveys.
- Because a small group
that show up on television
historically, look like such
douche bags nobody trusts.
(audience laughing)
- [Amy] So my question to
you is, on social media
for the long play, how do you build trust?
Like what kind of content?
- By not being a douche bag.
(audience laughing)
I mean it.
- [Amy] By being a douche bag that's how
you build the trust?
- By not.
- [Amy] By not.
I think, and I'm making a
joke and I'm trying to really
like frame up the conversation,
we as animals are always
inherently cynical to
something that feels fast.
By the way, it's my great
issue as a personality
I'm so Jersey fast hyper,
that so many people judge me
at first based on my energy
not the words out of my mouth.
There's so many people, how
many people here, watch this,
how many people here by
show of hands, started out
thinking I was full a
shit and a douche bag?
(audience laughing)
Right.
So like, thanks, so you know.
So I think it's how things
are said, it's the context,
everything is like have you
been wronged, I'm gonna hook
you up call this number now, we got this.
And it's just, it's built up.
Whereas instead nobody's educating,
who's putting out the
five minute video of like,
"Hey if this happens,
here are three things
you need to think of."
and be out.
And be out, not and call me,
or if you want more information
on how to really do it then you...
Everyone's so, basically
everyone in the industry
treats the customers the way
you know, scummy dudes go to
the bar at 11:30 at night,
they're trying to close in that moment.
(audience laughing)
And a little romance goes a long way,
right ladies?
Like just give me five fucking seconds.
(audience laughing)
Fuck.
That.
- [Amy] So on social media
then you're say just push out
as much educational content as you can.
- You know, and you
did raise your hand so,
you consume a little bit of my content?
- [Amy] Yes.
- Great, so you know how I
always say watch what I'm doing
not what I'm saying?
- [Amy] Yes.
- I am putting out my
best advice everyday,
there are literally
agencies that are built 100%
on the back of watching
my content in the m...
I get emails from, "Hey
Gary, funny story, my company
watches all your stuff in
the morning and then that's
what we sell, and we sometimes even steal
your own customers ha ha ha."
(audience laughing)
Two things run through my mind one, fuck
but for a second then I go,
"And that's why I'm gonna be
the top dog."
The world is abundant.
And there's confusion on that theory.
Too many people here think
they're competing directly
against the person next
to them, they're confused.
Number two, yes I think you
put out all the best content
you can possibly bring to somebody.
There are plenty of people
that never need to use you
and waste dollars, if you're
the lawyer in this room
that educates the world
of how not to use you
and waste dollars, you
will be the biggest person
in this room.
(audience clapping)
Doesn't come natural.
It's a little different,
but that's how the biggest
things in the world are built.
Of course you gotta play it
differently to be much bigger,
you can continue to play in
the margins grow 3%, 2%, 9%,
until you don't.
Sir,
how are you?
- [Man In Audience] Very good.
Hey Gary, how you doing?
Big fan.
- Thank you.
Oh I'm, you don't have a mic right?
The gentleman in the back with the mic,
you're gonna need to get
a mic brother, sorry.
Go ahead sir.
- [Anthony] Thank you, Anthony Knowles
from Phoenix, Arizona.
- Hey Anthony.
- [Anthony] You said
produce content at scale,
can you define what you mean by at scale?
- How much content do
you produce now, Anthony?
- [Anthony] Very little.
(audience laughing)
- You mean zero.
(laughing) I know you lawyers.
Here's what I would say, couple of things,
I think that Facebook and
LinkedIn is a really good place
for you to do original content,
I think Facebook groups
is an incredible place for you to join,
be part of the community
but don't go in hot.
You're just part of the
Arizona group of professionals
and you're bringing value,
and like when I started
my career you're part of
the community, which I know
has worked for a lot of
you that have an av..
The people in here who
haven't advertised leveraged
being part of the community
and built a word of mouth
kind of business, so I listen,
even if you did a thought
of the day.
How long have you been doing your job sir?
- [Anthony] 22 years.
- I think that is, you know
one of the things I'm talking
a lot about is, I believe one
of the most under conversated
issues in our society right
now when it comes to inclusion
and diversity, and acceptance, is ageism.
I am fascinated by the
growth of technology creating
a narrative where we completely
have not valued wisdom
and experience anymore,
and that if you're like
over 50 and your font size
on your text is big you suck.
(audience laughing)
I think that's completely backwards
and I actually think a huge opportunity
is to lean into experience.
I think if you did something called
you know, 22 seconds on
my 22 years of experience
on LinkedIn everyday and
you just talked about things
you learned or things you
thought, you will not believe
how much value for your
own business you get
when you bring value into the world.
Even if you talk about how
you built your practice
a fellow lawyer in Ohio may
subconsciously refer you
an opportunity, like doing
good and putting out good stuff
is always the right thing to do.
So I would, for you at
this point, just something
that made you do something consistent.
Notice how I framed up an
idea that seems kinda easy?
It's like, "Okay that's not."
You know, you see where I'm going?
The other thing you could
do is film, literally film
meetings and things of that
nature, obviously so much
you could never share with
disclosures and things
of that nature, but there might
be some internal meetings,
just getting into the habit.
This is no different
than being wildly obese
and out of shape, and you
have to start working out,
and you gotta start somewhere.
And if the first day
you're not running 47 miles
that's probably what the story is.
You know, like for most of
my life I didn't work out
and five years ago I got
serious, and that first work out
is the most laughable thing
to think about of all time.
You know, you gotta start somewhere.
If nothing else, just your
opening post, just everybody
leaves here today and
makes one post on LinkedIn.
LinkedIn's wild right now,
LinkedIn's going through
a Facebook like moment, you
could have no followers,
you could post something and
1,000 people will see it,
because there's so much
consumption and not enough content.
That is a tremendous, even if
you did a hello world post.
Hello LinkedIn, I'm starting
this, I'm gonna try,
I went to a morning keynote
that inspired me to do this,
I'm gonna start putting out
content of things of how
I built my firm, what I've
learned, things that I think
people should look out
for in my expertise, tips.
So that's what I would say sir.
- [Anthony] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Hi.
- [Ali] Hey.
Hey.
- [Ali] No we're good, what's up Gary?
I'm Ali Awad, and I get
my clients a lot of money.
My question is this.
- Jesus.
(audience laughing)
Go ahead bro.
- [Ali] So, there's a
huge age difference here,
some of us are in our
20's and 30's, some of us
are in our 50's and 60's.
Not a lot of us have the
benefit of being on billboards,
radio, t.v. ads for so many years.
So we wanna talk about
practicality, I know you bring
this up all the time.
I started doing some social
media right when I was
in law school, last year was
my first full year in business.
I spent about $6,000 in ads and made
a little over three million in revenue.
- Okay.
- [Ali] Realized, you
this shit kinda works.
- Right.
- [Ali] Practically, if you're
saying you made a specific
number $4,000 and you're putting
out mailers or billboards,
practically if someone
has $4,000 to spend where
do you think would be the best--
- Facebook.
- [Ali] Facebook ads only and is it--
- Yes.
- more important
in the marketing dollars
or in the content creation?
- The marketing amplification dollars.
The content creation when
you have such limited money,
should be you and a iPhone.
- [Ali] Okay.
- The distribution of
dollars, and the reason
I say Facebook, Facebook's
first of all, Facebook's
dominance from 50 to 90
year olds is remarkable
and there's a lot of
business to be done there.
So Facebook's not cool, I
don't give a fuck about cool,
I'm trying to build businesses out here.
So you can also be crazy
contextual on Facebook,
you know you're targeting
55 to 60 year old people
in Chicago, you make a
reference about the 86 Bears,
you make a reference about
Illinois, you make a reference,
you make context in your video.
You know who you're targeting.
Plus it costs nothing,
a 100 bucks to get into,
in front of in a feed,
a ton of people that
are 55 to 60 in Chicago.
Facebook.
- [Ali] Awesome, thank you.
- You got it.
Yes sir.
- [James] Uh James Dutton.
- Hey James.
- [James] I'm from here in
Georgia and in a very rural area.
- Okay.
- [James] There's several
attorneys in those various
counties that we practice
in, that for 40 years
for 50 years have just been killing it.
They're the brand.
- Makes sense.
- [James] If somebody wants
a criminal defense attorney
they go to this guy and that's it.
- I get it.
- Even thought that guys
retired and it's his associates now that
are the ones doing it.
How do you in that--
- Run a Facebook ad, to that area.
- [James] Yeah, how do I
overcome that level of--
- You make a video and
you say, "Hey everybody
in Thomas County, it's me.
Fun fact, you know George
Thompson that you all use,
he's been retired for 40
years and you're actually
getting Carol."
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
That would be the ad I would run.
And then I would quickly move and be like,
"And by the way, this has
nothing to do with George
Thompson and I'm sure Carol
is lovely, let me tell
you about me."
And then you'll build.
- [James] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience laughing)
Who's got the mics?
Let's make sure we spread out.
Hey sir,
yup.
- [Howard] Hey Gar.
- How are you?
- [Howard] I'm excellent.
I feel excellent.
- Good.
- [Howard] I'm Howard
Spiva, I'm a trial lawyer
from Savannah, Georgia.
- Okay.
- [Howard] I've got 35
Crisp videos, I have had
a charity since 1999.
I'm in all the parades,
here's a problem I have.
- Please.
- [Howard] Here's a problem I have.
- [Howard] I don't care what anyone says,
- Good.
- [Howard] if you have
someone who's catastrophically
injured you're never
gonna get full justice
unless you do one of two
things, go in the court room
and get it, or be willing
to go in the court room
and get it.
- Okay.
- [Howard] Otherwise they
laugh, because they paid
you three million at
mediation and they woulda paid
you 20 at trial.
- I understand.
- [Howard] Here's my problem,
those guys you're talking
about on t.v., in Savannah none of them,
the only one I've ever
seen at the court house
was getting sentenced for
stealing from his client.
(audience laughing)
They don't get full justice
and they sell people
down the river, they take the quick money,
most of the time they take
the million that's offered,
or they take the two or they
take the three at mediation
and that's it.
- Makes sense to me.
- [Howard] Yeah, well here's
the problem, I've got 43 years
in martial arts and I'm a warrior.
And I like to go in the court
room and change people's
lives and some people are so
badly injured you can't do
that unless you go in the court room,
but see they call the guy
on the truck or the hammer,
I mean I get calls I get cases,
I'm blessed beyond means,
but how do I keep.
- That's your fault.
- [Howard] That's right,
and so I need you to,
to tell me beyond what you've said--
- I just fucking told you
for the last 35 minutes.
(audience laughing)
- [Howard] Beyond what
you've said. (laughing)
- What you were just
saying was super compelling
and I genuinely believe
you much more than,
you know, other content,
and you need to put
that on Facebook, and
LinkedIn, and Twitter.
- [Howard] All right, well one question.
- Please.
- [Howard] It's nice to
go all over the country
and try cases but I don't want 50 states,
I don't even want our 159 counties.
We have unbelievable
commercial trucks with timber,
and logging, and the ports in Savannah,
those are the cases that I want.
I want all the catastrophic
injuries by trucking.
- So only run your ads in your area,
don't put out a single piece
of organic social media
content in your life,
only run content against
the target area.
You can run ads only to people
in the specific zip code
in the specific age group.
- [Howard] Okay.
- My friends, this is a
game of headline reading
versus being a practitioner,
the amount of opinions
in this room about what social media is,
or things of that nature, are opinions.
I run ads everyday.
I'm a practitioner.
Like you said sir, you're
a practitioner they play
one on t.v.
- [Howard] Right.
- I don't understand why
people don't spend 10 hours
on Google, or YouTube
consuming information to become
educated on how to make
pictures and videos and run ads
on the seven platforms that we all know
our society is living on.
To this young mans point,
there was never a time
when a young man with
6,000 bucks could build
that much revenue cause
it costs too much money
to do radio, tele...
Guys I built my Daddy's
store on radio, television,
and direct mail, it was hard.
This shit's way easier.
You just judge technology
cause you're old.
Or because you're
ideological, this is not a old
or new thing, there's a lot of
20 years olds that are like,
"I don't like that my
friends are on the phone."
I'm like, "Who gives a fuck?"
(audience laughing)
You're trying to sell tee
shirts they're on the phone,
go on the phone.
People are making decisions
about their marketing
of their business based
on their subjective
opinion of society.
Nobody cares about your
opinion that the kids
don't go outside,
nobody cares.
You think it's weird that
they use Tinder, fuck you.
(audience laughing)
I don't understand what we're doing here.
When did you have the
ability to judge society?
Who the fuck are you?
I'm serious.
By the way, I don't think my
opinions are right either,
I only, this is why I don't
guess, I promise you every word
that you're about to hear
has already happened.
I'm not guessing, because I
don't want the vulnerability,
this is not opinions.
Sir, run Facebook and
LinkedIn, you can run ads
on YouTube that are based
on what people search
on Google, if they're searching
for attorney in Savannah,
Georgia, but then they
go to YouTube to watch
a Georgia Bulldogs you know, highlight,
you could pop up and say, "Are
you from Savannah, Georgia?"
And they're gonna be like,
"Oh shit, that's weird."
(audience laughing)
But at least they're gonna
know who the fuck you are.
Cause you're losing the
people who they know
who the fuck they are.
- [Howard] Gotcha.
- Just like that dude back
there, just like everything else.
This is very obvious,
this is black and white.
I don't know what emotional
hurdle you need to get over
to get into this, I don't
know if you don't realize
how content you actually are,
I don't know if you don't
realize that the words
coming out of your mouth
from ambition don't match your action,
cause you don't actually mean it.
I don't know what, but
I know it's happening.
And that's what we need to
breakthrough here today.
- [Howard] Gary, I've
followed you for years,
read your books, I love
your energy, thank you.
- Thank you sir.
And my friend, as you can
imagine when I hear that
as the parting shot, and
I want you to win versus
the alternative, I need
you to start doing.
You need to leave this
conference right now
and go home, and run $1,000 worth of ads.
(audience clapping)
- [Howard] I'm a Crispx
client and I'm there running
on all those.
- Bro, I don't care if you're
fucking the Lord Jesus Christ,
(audience laughing)
I need you to go fucking home and run ads.
Thank you.
(audience clapping)
(laughing)
I like getting churchy in the south.
(audience laughing)
Yes.
- [Gabriel] Hey Gary, I'm Gabriel Sanchez
from Los Angeles.
- Gabriel, pleasure.
- [Gabriel] Big fan,
wake up every morning
- Thank you.
- on the treadmill
listening to your podcast
awesome.
- Thank you brother.
- [Gabriel] A lot of value, thank you.
- Thank you.
- [Gabriel] So personal
injury lawyer, Los Angeles,
I have some of the, it's
super fierce competition
- Yeah that makes sense.
- Sometimes I'm surprised
I even am still here.
- Exist, yeah.
- [Gabriel] I got guys
spending millions of dollars
a month in advertising,
some of the biggest firms
are in Los Angeles.
- Makes sense.
- [Gabriel] They're all over the world.
I got like 12 attorneys,
personal injury attorneys
just in my building
(audience laughing)
so, most of my business
it's all referral based.
- Makes sense.
- [Gabriel] Started off with
five clients about four years
ago, we have 190 now.
- Awesome.
- [Gabriel] My question
is, a lot these firms,
a lot of the big competitors
are, they're starting
to do the video ads,
they're starting to get on,
they're already on social
media paying Facebook,
Instagram they're doing that.
And...
- That's what pisses me off.
- Yeah and that's..
- Because I've been yelling
about this forever and I
wish you did it four years
and I don't know when, you
know, like yes that's what,
wait there's only one
feed, it's not like there's
a separate feed for
personal injury lawyers,
and then one for sneakers,
and then one for...
Wait til the biggest companies
in the world stop spending
on dumb fucking t.v.
commercials and start spending
properly here, the price
to get into a Facebook feed
is not gonna be 12 bucks,
it's gonna be 450 bucks.
My friends, this hasn't even started.
To answer to the punchline
of your question,
you have to be better.
More contextual, more specific,
just like early Google.
At first I bought wine, that was good.
But then everybody figured out the game,
then I had to buy cabernet, that was good.
Then everybody figured out the game.
Then I had to buy Caymus Cabernet.
Then everybody figured out the game,
then I had to buy Caymus
2004 Cabernet Sauvignon,
then everybody figured out the game.
Then I had to find some weird
Portugal wine and buy that.
You gotta get more specific,
you've gotta make a video
in Spanglish, half Spanish
half English only targeting
44 to 49 year old women
that live in San Diego,
in the outside, you see where I'm going?
And then you gotta make the vid..
You have to pick the target and then make
the video for them.
When I make a video of
like, "Hey 60 year olds
don't you hate all these
fucking 25 year olds
that are getting all
the action on YouTube?"
It explodes, cause I target 60 year olds
and they hate 25 year olds.
(audience laughing)
You understand?
- [Gabriel] That's genius, I love it.
- And what the big firms are gonna do is,
everyone in Los Angeles.
And so they're gonna
sell vanilla to everyone
and you need to sell
chocolate mint chocolate chip
triple decker, and you
need to make it contextual.
Got it?
- [Gabriel] Got it.
- I literally sit in
my office make a video
that's a macro point, and then
film for like five minutes
saying, hey Detroit, hey
Cleveland, hey, contextual.
This is a context battle
not a content battle.
- [Gabriel] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
Hey.
- [Brent] What's up, Gary?
Brent Sibley, personal
injury lawyer from Miami,
thank you for the selfie outside.
I'm actually already
- You got it.
- [Brent] running that selfie on Instagram
as an ad right now.
- I respect it.
I fucking love it.
- I shit you not.
I got--
- Just don't make it douchey.
- [Brent] No it's just me and you.
- I'll tell you what, you'll love this,
there's people that like
grab me in the street
we take a quick selfie or
in the airport, and then I'd
find cause they tagged me and
in the caption they're like
long full day meeting with Gary Vee,
strategizing the future.
(audience laughing)
- [Brent] Nope, just put
legend is in the house,
that's all I put.
- I appreciate it, and then
I jump in the comments,
I'm like, you're a fucking dick.
(audience laughing)
- [Brent] I knew you
were gonna call me out
if I put some bullshit in there.
So I'm not about to do that.
- Go ahead.
- [Brent] Anyway here
we go, about a year ago
I saw something from you
saying how under priced
stories were on Instagram--
- Yes, Instagram stories
right, just for everybody
there's the Instagram
main feed and the stories,
the ads in there are super
under priced still, keep going.
- [Brent] So I pretty
much took that to heart,
I was at point in my
life, have my first child,
said I need to make an
impact so I'm gonna go all in
on the stories.
The stories are linked to
my Instagram, my Facebook
are linked, and I have
about 1,000 followers
probably 10 people in the
room have already come up
to me from this week and
said, "I love your stories,
I'm going ham."
But it's a personal thing,
I'm all jabs, I'm not barely
asking for anything people love it.
How do I, I'm struggling
to push that, grow that,
and get my people to share
it when I put some ad budgets
on the stories people get
confused cause they're like,
who is this guy just talking
about being motivated
or having a child, he's
you know what I'm saying.
How am I gonna grow that personal brand?
- It means you're running the ads poorly.
Like think about it,
you're going too generic
with the ads so if you're
just showing up in a random
persons feed in story ads
and you gave them no context
on you, then you become
vulnerable cause you're back
to the vanilla business.
Whereas if you targeted,
where do you live?
- [Brent] Miami, Aventura.
- Right, if you're like, "Miami, what's up
or you could target Dol, are you
a fucking Dolphin's fan?
- [Brent] No.
(audience laughing)
- Worse?
- [Brent] No, no, no,
I've gave up on the NFL
a long time ago.
- Respect.
Do you like anything?
- [Brent] I like Tiger Woods.
He went through a huge battle--
- You gave up on the NFL
but not on Tiger Woods?
(audience laughing)
- [Brent] And I've been proven right.
- There's some hypocrisy
shit going on in here today.
Anyway, what you need
to do is not run vanilla
to vanilla, you need to
go a little more specific
with those and you need
to create some context,
and you need to say it
right away cause you have
a second in the story.
So which, it was fun that
this was the transition
notice how I said, I record hey Cleveland,
that hey Cleveland before
I go into parenting
or whatever is what
keeps somebody in there,
cause they're like, "I'm from Cleveland."
- I got that on a podcast.
- And then if I make
a Bone Thugs and Harmony reference,
now we're really tripping.
(audience laughing)
Got it?
You have to bring context.
So that's why and then
as for the first part
the right hook, like if
you're looking for something
for them to use you or what
have you, it's okay to ask.
Like nobody's trying to
give more value than me,
but you're wearing my
sneakers, this gentleman
is wearing my sneakers, I'm
not even wearing my sneakers,
because when I have something
to sell I'm happy to ask.
It will not convert as
well as the dream sounds,
not enough people buy
Empathy Wines for the value
I've given them, not enough
people sign up for Wine Text,
not enough people use
VaynerMedia, not enough people
use, you know, buy K-Swiss
sneakers for all the value
I'm giving which is free
and at scale, and the best
in the world, but the
bottom line is that's okay.
Give, give, give and then
ask, because the net is still
bigger because the casket is so wide.
Is it sometimes sad?
I mean I, bro, you know how
weird it is to get emails,
"Hey Gary Vee, nine years
ago I was super poor
and now I have 47 million
dollars because all I did
was watch your videos and did it."
And then I'll reply only
once out of every ten times
because I like learning,
"Hey bro, by the way,
did you buy Empathy wines?"
"Oh no, I didn't get to it bro."
Fuck.
(audience laughing)
47 million, couldn't throw a guy a case?
You know,
as long as you understand
that give, give, give
too many people when they
give, and this is what
is wrong with 90% of the
marketing in this room,
when they give they have
expectation to get in return.
Which means that they're not
giving they're manipulating.
That's what free eBooks
are but then you get them.
That's what a free consultation
call, fuck you guys.
(audience laughing)
You're not giving me any value,
you mean an opportunity to
be sold to the whole time?
Fuck.
You know it and I know
it, and most importantly
they know it.
Why don't you actually give
a free consultation call
film it, tell the person
you're filming it,
"Hey Ron, I'm giving you
this free consultation call,
I'm filming it for my
Facebook because I feel very
comfortable with what I'm gonna
say, is that okay with you?"
"No, it's not okay with me."
"No problem, we won't film."
"Hey Karen, I'm about to give
you this free consultation
call, just want you to know
I wanna film it and put
it on my Facebook is that okay with you?"
"Yeah, that's fine."
And then actually give
the best possible advice
that may lead not even
having a transaction
and then put that video
on Facebook and LinkedIn
and watch your miraculous
lead gen explode.
There's a tactic.
There's more details, there you go.
Hi how are you?
- [Kat] Hi my names Kat Tomeny, I'm from
Baton Rouge, Louisiana.
- Hi Kat.
- [Kat] My husband over
here is the trial lawyer.
- I see him.
Good looking dude, good job.
- [Kat] I'm a huge fan.
- Thank you.
- I love, I have
a lot of your personality traits.
- Good, you must be amazing.
- [Kat] I am.
(audience laughing)
But the biggest, I just
started helping Frank
with his marketing at the office,
because he's been practicing 32 years,
top trial lawyer Louisiana.
My biggest concern is we
handle like quadriplegics
catastrophic accidents.
- Yes, I understand,
sensitive stuff.
- [Kat] I just don't,
I don't know where to begin with that.
- Well you don't share that.
It's no different than
me choosing not to share
my children because I don't
wanna put them on blast,
and I'll let them decide
if they wanna be known.
Instead of what most people
do, which is it's cute,
and they get three extra
likes and they don't think.
You're not gonna put out
content, what are you gonna ask
for somebody in such a ter...
This is why I love you already.
One I love him because he
looks he could beat the shit
out of anybody.
(audience laughing)
Two, I love you because you're
asking the right question.
That's so awesome, of course not.
What are you gonna ask
somebody to make a video
that's in such a terrible spot
for your own personal gain?
Of course you're not.
So you don't.
You don't need to do that, I'm
not looking for testimonials
out here, nobody believes them anyway.
Let me save you time,
nobody believes them anyway.
Hi, I see you.
What's that I see it.
Great, for the one minute left?
Yeah, I'm gonna go a little late.
So.
(audience clapping)
I,
they don't believe in
testimonials anyway, I'm looking
for him to story tell
about certain things he saw
from the mindset of I don't
want this video on Facebook,
or LinkedIn, or Twitter,
to lead to business.
I want it to lead to
reputation and legacy,
which then will happen
to lead it to business.
When you go into that mind
frame, all of a sudden
he's telling like, you know real stuff.
Like, you know, I still
continue to tell everybody,
which is why I do what I
do, of trying to get service
providers to tell people
how not to use them.
Or to your point sir, over there.
Like really educating them
why settlements are so high,
it's no different.
By the way I'm going
through this in my business,
my brother and I have a sports
representation business,
it's new VaynerSports, you
know every kid in Georgia
you have to recruit what a talented state.
None the less, a lot of agents,
oh Atlanta just benefited from this,
Ronald Acuna just signed
a long term contract
that was so horrible
for Ronald Acuna but great for the Braves,
because his agent wanted to sign it early
because they didn't wanna
lose him before arbitration.
Tell truth.
The truth always wins,
you don't need to go into
that content, maybe they want
you to go into that content.
Maybe that person who is
in a super bad situation
enjoys watching his videos
cause when they googled
before they started working
with you, they watched
15 of them and he happens to be funny.
And it's interesting,
and they were so grateful
at the end of the process
they actually tell you,
I'd like to do a video
with you, and then you can
if you want.
But don't let it be a
testimonial tell the joke
about the fries you ate.
- [Kat] So we just did the
video and it came out great.
- Okay.
- [Kat] There's some
parts that I'm, you know,
we'll market on Facebook
and stuff like that,
and maybe some for our
website I think, yeah.
- Okay, but I need you
to make content everyday.
- [Kat] Okay.
- Like, I wanna know what
he thinks is gonna happen
with the LSU game tonight.
Like this is about building reputation.
Guys, we did this in the
cafe's, and at the PTA,
and at the chamber of
commerce, and at the stop sign,
at the high school football game,
it's how you build your business.
All I'm asking you to do is
what you did in real life,
to do digitally.
You didn't roll up to everybody
at, when you first started
your career and said, "Use me."
No, you started networking.
You can network with content.
- [Kat] Thank you.
- You got it.
Sir, or okay we'll go there yup, ma'am.
How are you?
- [Woman In Audience]
I'm doing great, Gary.
- Awesome.
- [Woman In Audience] The
question I have and I know
you've told us,
build content, brand,
reputation as a means of
basically early adaptation,
but you know people
and you know what they
think about lawyers,
what other kind of things can
we do to be early adapters
in this field that you can think of?
- Keep the mic, I wanna
make sure I understand
the framework of your question.
When you say early adopters,
cause you were going
towards the end of that
question around trust,
and then you kind of pivoted
a little bit there at the end
with early adopters, so
what I wanna understand
is are we talking about
the content you can put out
on the places where people currently are
or start building early
reputation on things
like Tik Tok or when anything come?
Go ahead.
- [Woman In Audience] Well,
I'm thinking like adaptation,
like you did with your
wine business, you know
you were out there you did
Google before anybody else
did Google, and yes that
you're providing value,
providing value but one of
the things that's a threat
is that people think
lawyers are just out there
to money grub.
Most of the lawyers I know
are out there to help people.
Yes we like getting paid for our work,
but that's why we do what we do.
And so--
- I think that's the content
that needs to seed the earth.
- Okay.
- That's what so exciting
about this.
The last generation of content
to this gentleman's point,
was people that were more
marketers than they were lawyers,
I think that you should
put out a podcast each week
and talk about helping people.
You could, and I think leveling
up your ideas works too.
Like if you started,
where do you live ma'am?
- [Woman In Audience] Um Colorado.
- Great, if you started the you know,
you know Colorado helping people podcast,
literally the CHP.
Welcome to the first episode of the CHP,
today I'm interviewing Karen
Thompson an incredible doctor
from downtown Denver, and
the whole macro of the show
is helping people, as the
show brings people value
even a small group of 400
people that listen to it
in Colorado, the likelihood
of 12 of those people
using you once they...
You don't even have to say what
you do and they'll probably
become your clients.
And notice how I called it
the Colorado because I want it
to be narrow so that it's
a small listenership,
but it's contextual, and
you'll get the benefit.
- [Woman In Audience]
Well and that's actually
less my concern is me getting the benefit,
but how we might be able
to reach and provide things
to the consumers.
Like again, you know what people want
and I mean, that's what you give 'em.
And you give 'em, but I don't
know exactly how to bridge
that gap between you know,
hey come in my office,
sit down I'll talk to you about things
and bill you hourly.
What ideas you know, I guess
what more my point was,
what can we do to really
provide value to the end user?
- Do a Q and A show.
- [Woman In Audience] Okay.
- One of the things I did
in 2013 or 14 was I started
the ask Gary Vee show,
because I took questions
and if you have a LinkedIn,
or a Facebook, or a Twitter,
you can post, anybody have
a legal question of me,
you take four of them
and you do a Q and A show
and you answer it, and now
you're providing value.
- [Woman In Audience] Yeah, excellent.
Thank you.
- Q and A's a great way
to start.
- [Woman In Audience] Thanks Gary.
- You got it.
Sir.
- [William] Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- [William] My name's
William, I'm with my wife
at CrashATO.com.
I got a good question.
You're big in the black community online,
how are you able to translate
the different cultures
and you know,
and actually win.
- (chuckles) Because most people try to go
into cultures and take.
- [William] But a lot
of my counter part here,
do take but I'm saying how
can I take as a minority
in this game, you know?
- Well I mean look, whether
it's African Americans,
you know I grew up in the
Soviet former, like a lot
of community likes to work
with that community, right?
So you already have a leg up.
It's just that you have to
note whether you look like you,
or me, or that lovely lady
that just asked a question
at the macro it's value.
- [William] Okay.
- The reason athletes and
hip hop artists like me
is when I DM Gunna when he has
800 followers on Instagram,
and I speak to him about
navigating how to build up
his profile,
he remembers that.
I'm not hitting up Gunna
today, I'm not hitting up
Dababy today, I'm hitting
them up when they're on
the come up and trying to give
them game that allows them
to navigate business.
That's why it works, and even better,
I asked them for nothing, because
I know reputation matters.
You know, the reason we're
gonna break the whole
sports agency game and do
the whole Jerry Maguire
on everybody's face is, cause
we're gonna bring more value
to the kids, it's not super complicated.
So the way you breakthrough
is A, if for example
you wanna go after the
African American community
you know you already got a leg
up, they're gonna trust you
more on the get and all you have to do
is provide them value.
You don't take advantage of
that you lean into bringing
more value, it's empathy.
- [William] Appreciate it.
- Sir.
- [Man in Audience 2] Hey thanks so much
for all your comments, love 'em.
So you know with my firm
we've started doing Facebook,
and LinkedIn, I wanted to
know if there's any other
platforms you'd recommend
to start you know shuffling
a little bit of the ads to.
- How much money and content
a day do you spend on Facebook
and LinkedIn?
- [Man In Audience 2] We
spend about two grand a month.
- Right, Facebook and LinkedIn.
- [Man In Audience 2] Okay,
and there's no other platforms
like Instagram stories.
- Facebook,
LinkedIn.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
One final question.
- And here's why I like
Instagram stories, I do think
they're grossly under
priced, but I love Facebook
and LinkedIn cause it's
very, very, very much going
to be a place where a lot
of people here do business.
There's business to be done
and if you've been listening
and you go narrow, and you go
demographic, psychographic.
Sir, it's contextual, even
the words I was using with you
are more, like it's not acting different
it's just relevance.
People have different
slang terms, I can't go
to the upper east side and
talk to an 84 year old woman
and use the word slat,
she's not gonna know what
the fuck I'm saying.
So you have to be contextual,
right, slang matters.
That's not disrespectful
that's being a chameleon
and being empathetic,
if you actually mean it.
So, you know the thing
that I want you to do
is really be contextual
on those two platforms
cause they're grossly under
priced with their targeted ads.
LinkedIn is under priced on organic.
Now if you post organic
you might get somebody
from Saint Louis, I don't
know how your industry works,
I assume maybe I'm wrong,
that referral business
is a potential so if you have
somebody super interested
in you but you're here and
you don't wanna litigate
or can't in Saint Louis.
Thank you for confirming I
assumed, I mean I'd probably be,
I can walk into your business
tomorrow and in three years
make more revenue than everybody
here just on referrals.
Don't make me do that.
(audience laughing)
It would hurt your fucking feelings.
It's what I did in the ad
world, I was the liquor store
guy coming to Madison Avenue
billion dollar companies,
they took shits on me until they didn't.
It's all the same fucking game.
That's why I'm walking
into sports, I could walk
into anything.
Whoever provides the
most value always wins,
it just takes a few minutes.
People aren't patient.
They can't wait to get
that first check to buy
that dumb shit to impress
people that they don't
even give a fuck about.
- [Man In Audience 2] One--
(audience clapping)
- That's what's really happening out here.
- [Man In Audience 2] Final
question, what do I have to do
to get a selfie with you?
My wife said don't come home--
- Run up here right now sir.
- [Man In Audience 2] Awesome.
(audience clapping)
- Oh you're actually running, shit.
(audience laughing)
You took that very literally.
- My wife said don't come
home without a selfie.
Awesome.
- Real pleasure.
- Thank you.
- Take care.
(audience clapping)
- [Russel] Hey Gary, my names Russel.
- How are you?
- Doing good how are you?
- Good.
- [Russel] I've been
practicing law 16 weeks and--
(laughing)
(audience clapping)
- You know what's funny?
You delivered that so
great, you even got me,
and I'm looking it's a little dark,
and I'm like you know how
you're brain can work fast,
I'm like this man's about to say 16 years,
did he start when he was four?
(audience laughing)
Go ahead.
- [Russel] Well and my
background was in video marketing
before I went to law school,
so I know this shit works
but now I work for my
Father and his partner
who are the 70 year old
guys who are gonna retire
in six years and,
- Okay.
- They just wanna preserve the business.
And one of the partners complains
about spending 400 bucks
a month on his legal
library for online research
instead of books.
So how do I convince them
in the value of this stuff
that I know is gonna work?
Cause I'm, I'm gonna be
running the business one day.
- One of two ways.
A, you deploy empathy and
wait your fucking turn
cause they built a huge business.
(audience clapping)
Or you do B, which is what
I did, which is put heavy
pressure on the system on
a daily barrage of words
until they succumb to your annoyance.
(audience laughing)
(audience clapping)
You know what's really interesting about,
and I know I got a wrap
up I'll try to bang one
or two more out, but what
was really interesting about
the answer to that gentleman's
question if you heard both
of my versions, it's probably
the best way I can sum up
how I think about the world.
This is about practicality.
The answer I just gave that
young man is actually practical,
in a family business dynamic
when somebody new comes in,
who absolutely often is
much more right about
the contemporary way to do
something, often there's too much
audacity and lack of patience,
and it's like whatever.
And we don't take into account
that these two gentlemen,
the father and the partner,
had worked 45 years to build
this thing that we get to walk into.
And we just need to deploy patience.
I wanna remind everybody
of my story cause it means
a lot to me.
I walked into my Dad's
business, I built the business
from three to 60 million
dollars, I worked seven days
a week for 15 hours a
day, and at 34 years old
I left that business owning nothing.
And I never paid myself
anywhere close to the proper
amount cause we poured all the
money back into the business.
I was an executive that
built something from three
to 60 million and never
made over $120,000 a year,
because that's old school family stuff.
And at 34 I had no net
worth, cause I didn't own
the business, cause if
you're part of an immigrant
or family business you know how it works.
You don't get it until they fucking die.
(audience laughing)
So I then started my next
business, VaynerMedia,
out of the conference
room of another company
cause I didn't have money for rent.
And that's why it's easy
for me to tell people
to be patient.
That's why I believe in this.
That's why I believe doing the right thing
is always the right thing.
Yes sir.
- [Edward] Edward Lake from
Long Island in Florida.
Two questions for ya, first.
- First of all your voice alone
(audience laughing)
- [Edward] Good or bad?
- Great.
- Okay.
- Brother, I can monetize
that thing for at least
10 million.
- [Edward] Okay we could talk,
we could talk, we could talk.
(audience laughing)
- Go ahead.
- [Edward] I could do some voice overs.
- Let's go.
- [Edward] How do you handle
when somebody wants--
- By the way, by the way,
I apologize.
This matters.
I wanna talk about real life.
I have a funny feeling that
not every person in this rooms
dream and happiness
forever is being a lawyer.
Let's talk about this.
Sir, I believe if you made
videos the way I'm talking about
that it is a not a
ridiculous thing to believe,
that somebody would reach out to you cold
saying, "Hey."
What's your name again sir?
- [Edward] Ed.
- Ed, "Hey Ed," it's perfect, "Hey Ed,
(audience laughing)
you know I happened to catch your,
you know your video
about this legal issue,
have you ever considered voice over?"
And then miraculously,
this is real, this is real,
this is how the world is actually working.
I know you didn't grow
up with something called
the internet that opened up every gate
and there's no gate keepers anymore.
And was gonna completely
eliminate the value
of all the gate keepers.
College, resumes, and
all sorts of other shit,
but now we're living in it.
And so anyway,
I just wanted.
- And so now I get
to ask my question?
- Go ahead.
(audience laughing)
See even your person,
I fucking love you, Ed.
(audience laughing)
- [Edward] Here's my question,
everybody wants to do
business with you personally,
when they hire your media
company they want you.
- You're wrong, Ed.
Ed, you're wrong.
- And that's what
I'm asking you is--
- Well I'm giving you the fucking answer.
- How do you--
- By telling them up front
you don't fucking get me.
- [Edward] So, you're
branding yourself, but
they're not getting you.
- Because my organization
follows my fucking religion.
- [Edward] But when you're a trial lawyer.
- Ed.
- [Edward] Wait a minute
this is important.
When you're a trial
lawyer your reputation,
a lot of it is based--
- So charge more, Ed.
- [Edward] No, no it's
based on your prior--
- I understand where you're going brother,
yes I sure do.
- No you don't.
They want you.
- [Edward] Correct, now
I'm gonna give 'em to
an associate and they're
gonna go but I wanted you.
- Ed, there's only two fucking things
when you sell yourself.
You either tell them they
don't get you up front
but Susan and Ricky are
your fucking cronies
and this is how we do it,
or you say you want me, pay
me fucking five times more.
There's people paying me $100,000 an hour
to consult.
- And that's my question.
So, but wait a minute.
- Charge more, Ed.
- [Edward] But wait a minute,
so what you're saying to me
is you personally is
worth more than the people
who work for you, so then
when you're handing them off
to the people who work
for you, you're saying
they're not as good as me
because I'm not charging as much.
- That's exactly what I'm
saying, Ed, but what I'm saying
to them is my people are
better than the alt..
Ed, you just have to be better
than the fucking alternative.
- [Edward] Show me that,
why are your people better
than somebody who's now
branding themself who has
time for me personally?
That's really my issue.
How do you take a law firm
- Because I'm..
- With 30 lawyers
- I'll tell you
- And market yourself
- I'm in the same business
as you brother.
I'm literally in the same business as you,
I'll tell you why.
Because I'm a better fucking operator.
- [Edward] Okay.
- Cause I educate my people,
because I have process.
- [Edward] But you have to be,
you have to show, you have
to get people to believe
that's the truth rather
than oh I'm branding
and then I'm just gonna
turn it off cause I really
don't wanna do the work.
- Yes Ed,
that is how life works.
Yes I have to get them
to believe it, but here's
what I do.
If I sense they don't, and many don't, Ed.
- [Edward] Okay.
- I don't try to convince them.
I go to the next guy or gal.
- [Edward] Fair enough, okay.
(audience clapping)
The second part of this, how do you handle
the negative reviews which
you seem to get a lot,
I read you all, you know I'm on..
And we get, part of the
reason, okay let me back up,
- Please.
- We do a lot,
a lot of Facebook advertising.
- Yes sir.
- [Edward] Five, six figures a month
sometimes.
- Love you.
- [Edward] And when you put
a Facebook ad, a legal ad,
Round Up everybody's probably seen it,
you get 90% of negative
reviews and I'm concerned about
that hurting the reputation
of your law firm
- Can I ask you a question?
- Already exists,
- That's a great,
as you should
- And how do you handle
those negative reviews.
- I reply to them as often as I can.
Keep it with Ed a little bit
here cause I'm wrapping up
and just in case, cause
Ed's asking great questions
and we might bring some value here.
Number one, how long have you been running
five or six figures on Facebook?
- [Edward] A couple
years probably, a year.
- So my intuition is actions
over words are important,
so I have a funny feeling,
Ed, cause I can you feel you.
Cause I see your no shlmeal,
I have a funny feeling
you continue to believe
that that's a good thing
for your business.
- [Edward] I do.
- Here's why, here's why it's working.
Attention as I started this talk with,
is the number one asset in society.
As much as people don't believe lawyers,
people actually don't believe
other people's reviews
as much as we think they do.
- [Edward] Okay fair enough they have--
- And that's why it's
working for you right,
you've been doing it for a couple years--
- [Edward] I don't know when
you see it's the amount,
I don't understand it, because
if I look at the comments,
90% are negative, yet I'll
get leads all day long.
So I can't really understand--
- I gave you the answer.
Because people don't believe
other peoples reviews
as much as you think they do.
And because it's your
baby, just like when people
say things about my
company, it hurts more.
It's funny to say some other kids ugly,
but when they say that about your kid
you wanna fucking kill.
- [Edward] Right.
- So you're taking it in
that way which makes sense,
but the other people don't which
is why you're getting leads
all day, that's the actual insight.
It's no different than my
favorite thing that's happening
in society now, everybody's
all about, and they're
hashtagging on social media,
about me too and black lives
matter, and the bottom
line is, 99% of people
fucking talk and they act different.
(audience clapping)
I'm glad that everybody's
a social media warrior,
I love all the keyboard
warriors and then people go
and fucking do totally different actions,
and because we know that about ourselves
that's why we don't believe in
reviews as much as you think.
Thanks, Ed.
- [Edward] Sure.
- And thank you Atlanta.
(audience clapping)
Thank you guys.
♪ Everybody's hands go up ♪
Thank you.
♪ Go up, go up ♪
Thank you so much.